[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey everyone i'm brian wood pr manager
at wolfram
i'm here with john woodard who is the
ceo of wolfram blockchain labs
how's it going john that's pretty good
all things considered i know we got
a whole multitude of things going on
both here and the world but
yeah all things considered pretty good
of course well that's that's good to
hear
uh john john's here to give me the
lowdown on wolfram blockchain labs
uh and kind of let me know what they've
been up to over the past year
so uh first i guess just give us a
little bit of an overview
uh what exactly is wolfram blockchain
labs uh where did it come from how did
it get started
yeah absolutely um so first
i just introduced myself of course i'm
john ordered um
i'm i have an undergrad in economics
background and a grad in
engineering so i'm kind of feel like i'm
maybe a little bit well positioned for
blockchain
or decentralized technologies because
it's kind of interesting
it's like it's not only like a
technology
sort of part to it but then it's also
like um
affecting kind of social areas as well
and then also kind of like legal too
so it's kind of all of these areas are
different tracks
so there's almost like this movement
around
blockchain and decentralized
technologies
um just just in general yeah yeah it's
been interesting seeing
a lot of otherwise disparate groups of
people sort of coming together on on
blockchain where you're like oh you know
you've got a little bit of the
you know the social side the technology
side the mathematics side you know
there's
yeah a lot going on there yeah exactly
like you have like
um folks who are kind of in this um i
guess it was a cypherpunk
kind of movement maybe that started in
the
uh 90s there was a whole mailing list
and everything so it's been like
really percolating through like
different subgroups in society so it's
really the social movement around
um privacy and so you have like a lot of
folks interested in cryptography
which i was not until like
until sort of getting more involved but
kind of what i found is you have to um
because it's kind of this movement you
have to buy into it a bit
um so like for me that means like you
have to
or like maybe in like crypto speak in a
way you have to kind of take your fiat
money
and put some of that into crypto
put your crypto where your mouth yeah
exactly exactly um
again like not no investment advice it's
not investment
yeah but like yes i think you kind of
have to like
really participate in the social kind of
aspects of it
so i think kind of having like a social
science background a bit
and engineering background a bit has
helped in that
um and like you said brian like as far
as like
you see a lot of different groups kind
of come together i think that's a really
astute observation
um when it comes to your question about
wolfram blockchain labs
i think really what happened um at
wolfram was that they're
like naturally again because there's a
social movement and
companies are made up of people a lot of
people within
wolfram um research
were interested in different um
cryptography
areas uh blockchain
privacy kind of areas and so they were
interested in bitcoin
as it came out um
and so what happened actually with wolf
from alpha was that
our users were making requests you know
what's the price of bitcoin
um and so we as the alpha team does they
they add more features to alpha and then
internally people were interested in
doing stuff with blockchain as well
um so we did that there um then in 2018
we kind of formalized
from blockchain labs as a subsidiary and
we then like pulled together all of
these areas in the company
that were really working about things
and kind of um
in a way centralized our
we we centralized our expertise and um
the projects
about decentralized uh technology
yeah so there's always that irony yes
you gotta sort of get the experts
together
in order for them to to you know split
everything apart
yeah exactly exactly uh so that's kind
of how that
that worked out okay cool
yeah i i mean and it does make sense
that you would end up the ceo of
you know blockchain labs like you said
from your background and interests
um so what kinds of projects do you work
on uh at wolf and blockchain labs then
yeah so they're really kind of four
areas that we work on
um one are like
i'll just start kind of with the the
most foundational
in a way we do um well i suppose that's
debatable but i'm just going to go in
this order
blockchain integrations where we
actually work with
blockchain companies that are out there
or distributed ledger
um technology companies that are out
there
um those companies themselves kind of
come
in a couple different flavors in a way
there are
um for-profit companies and then there
are
non-profit foundations but our
blockchain integration
work really centers around those
companies where we connect
those ledgers to the wolfram language
and we really make the data that they
have
on those ledgers um those will be
either the exchange of like crypto on
the ledgers
they'll be smart contracts and other
stuff we connect that to the wolfram
language so it's accessible
and computable so that's kind of the
foundational thing that we
we do in a way or one of the
foundational things
then the other thing that we do is um
really what wolfram research
in many ways is known for um we work
with
computational facts um and so when it
comes to
um of course like fly almost lands on my
nose
um that showed like
i'm committed but also like i guess
watching this stuff
um so when it comes to computational
knowledge i think where
it's really a foundational thing for for
wolfram in many ways
i really feel like that's a really big
strength that we have at wolfram
blockchain labs
um where we're taking that computational
knowledge and providing that through
what's called like oracle services
to smart contracts that run
on blockchains or run in like a
distributed fashion
um so that's
another really big area for us and where
we have this unique advantage
because um as you know brad like wolf
from alpha has been around for like
10 years commercially and even before
that kind of as a skunk works project
within wolfram research it's around it
it started like maybe five years before
that
so it's kind of been around for like 15
years
um on the the computable data side of
things
and on the algorithmic side of things i
think that's
part of stephen wolfram's vision from
the foundation
of um mathematica and wolfram language
like over 30 years ago
so we're like building on these huge set
of tools
um for this area of
smart contracts so it's like or
computational contracts which would be
like the more complex
kind of version of smart contracts so
these contracts themselves need um
i think kind of in the legal kind of way
they talk about them being like
operational clauses
and that's to say you have some
information that then would trigger a
clause so like
you need to um know whether it's
rained or not you need to know um
whether something really to kind of
generalize it something happened in the
world
or not and so one of the cool things is
we can take really
you know 30 plus years of
knowledge around um that's available
in our algorithmic base and available in
our knowledge base
and really apply that to this relatively
new problem which i think
shows like the foresight of um
stephen wolfram and wolfram research in
general and so it's like as a subsidiary
it's pretty great to like
to use this great technology to do stuff
um so that's computational facts
then the next area i would say is crypto
analytics
um and this kind of is really cool
because we've seen interest
here from actually crypto hedge funds um
who they're
they're trading with digital assets and
really there's going to be this
long-term kind of migration of um
assets to digital ass digital assets
and when you look at like again like
these foundational
dlts that are out there this is one of
the major use cases um
so um i would say like
ethereum which a lot of people call
maybe the the second generation
of uh ledgers that's like really one of
their major use cases
with smart contracts was to make all of
these tokens
many of the tokens that people see out
there now um
they came about because of the erc20
standard
contract on solidity which is on
in in solidity which on on um ethereum
so you have these
you know financial services that are now
trading
um wolf from language again has this
huge array of tools
for um financial reporting yeah um
charts and graphics and other sort of
visualizations
so kind of there were again like
building with
um these tools on top of this already
great foundation of stuff
so that's kind of this crypto asset
analytics area
and then lastly or firstly and this is
why i chuckled about the foundational
thing
is education so again like we have
this huge strength in education um we're
used
you know globally in
from like k-12 to
um higher education to
r d and industry to production areas
we're used all over the place but
education i think is
is this area where um people are using
us
all over the place um and so we're
really good i think
you guys at the wolfram league will from
you team who's like behind the great
production
of this video as well we're doing so
many great things there
and here's this new area where there's
social stuff there's a technology
component and there's a legal component
so that really fits in well i think with
uh
a lot of um drive in
you know higher education to kind of
meld technology and learn about
where the world is going so education we
have
um a mooc where we're just
on the cusp we have like visualizations
and other stuff that we need to do to
complete it
um but that's really this other area
that's really cool that we've been
working on
yeah and i i can vouch that uh those
wolfram u uh
courses can be very very in-depth and
are usually pretty impressive so
i know it takes a lot of work to get
those together for sure yes
yes indeed and like thanks again to the
the wolf from you team
yeah and uh yeah so it sounds like you
you sort of
just as as you said the
cross-disciplinary nature of
blockchain seems to have led will from
blockchain labs to a very
cross-disciplinary kind of uh
approach to things where you've got uh
you know a little bit of the
knowledge retrieval a little bit of the
analytics
a little and obviously like you said the
education seems like
seems almost obvious from uh
from just everything else that you are
working on so
so what else uh what have you what
specific kinds of things
have you been doing that are kind of new
with blockchain labs in the last year or
so
yeah absolutely so great question um
i would say one that like just to point
out to those of
folks who have attended wtc
or of 2020 or are going to attend
um it's great because we actually have
a uh i think a long talk where we go
into more technical detail
so if you're watching this like on some
social media
that you should if you can
go to wtc if you didn't see if you can
get a ticket
retroactively in some way um
but yeah so our team has worked really
hard this year and
uh i would love to mention everybody but
i know it's like really short
time and i'm probably going over but
johan and christian and the team have
really done
a lot of great work on extending our
core platform
for blockchain integrations and that's
like the actual thing that
folks connect to um right that we
actually use to connect
different blockchains to our platform um
what we've done is actually begun to
create
and are very close to having available
is a blockchain integration framework to
make it
easier for us to connect and for other
people to connect as well
um so that's a really cool development
um
over the past year and that's really
cool and also that
of course like with that we have like
some announcements
on new deals as well unfortunately like
i can't
break those over this but um those
should come out
um at some point too so that's that's
really great to see
can you could you give uh people an idea
of what blockchains we do already
connect to though
yeah absolutely so right now we connect
to
bitcoin um and that's like
bitcoin btc
ethereum eth ethereum
arc which is pretty cool we worked with
those guys so those
those guys are great multi-chain
which we have an instance of multi-chain
they're a permissioned blockchain
so that's kind of what um consortiums
use
to uh create um
consortium blockchain groups that's kind
of like
because they use a permissioned uh
blockchain the public
can't have access to that so when i
mentioned like bitcoin
and arc and ethereum those are all
public blockchains and we not only have
their mainnet
but we also have uh test net versions uh
as well and you can access those you
know right now go to our documentation
and access those right now
um in wolfram language um and you can
both
read the transactions from those or the
smart contracts from those and you can
also
write or send transactions to those
blockchains
through wolfram language so those are
the ones that we have now again like
great questions so people get more
context
and again like what we have are like
deals where we're adding more
blockchains and so that's pretty
exciting yeah yeah
so yeah so without getting you know
without giving away any uh trade secrets
or anything
uh can you tell us a little bit about
what what you have planned for the
future of blockchain labs
yeah sure um just to go back a little
bit too like we've expanded with
computational facts with crypto
analytics and like
education like i said we're on the edge
of the release with for the future
um i think in general let me like
say that it's always surprising to me in
many ways that
um people think about
the future in kind of physical terms in
many ways
and what i mean by that is people are
constantly thinking about electron
uh electrical vehicles
um there were big announcements from
some of those companies today in terms
of battery
technology or yesterday as well um
so it's kind of like people have this
view of the future
that's often in very physical terms but
they're not always thinking about the
future in terms of software
um and i'll tell you from like just an
engineering background in a way that
like
it's going to be faster um or we'll see
a lot of things
a lot of efforts and a lot of
developments faster and kind of that the
software
space than we will see in like the the
physical space
um so it's always amazing that like
the the physical space not only captures
people's minds
um but they're also like thinking about
these visions of the future there not
always thinking about the vision
of the the future with software and i
think
again with um
when you look at like this social aspect
of decentralized space
the um technology aspect
and the the legal aspect again there's
just going to be this huge change in the
future
um when it comes to software and how it
affects our lives i mean we look at
smartphones we look at computers
we look at kind of augmented reality
like now people walk around with you
know earbuds
that's augmented reality watches
augmented reality in a way
as far as like the monitoring your
your heart rate um other items
uh your oxygen levels etc with you know
you can do with your watch
um all tied into your your phone
um it's kind of amazing like we're
already living in this augmented reality
um and the same is true for these
computational contracts
that we think about it they're going to
be out like
just behaving autonomously yeah and i
think wolfram is going to be
at the core of that because we've done
so much work
a lot of heavy lifting in the past to
have the algorithm base
and the knowledge base to interact with
those computational contracts
and trigger these decisions about the
world so if we're thinking about like
what we see physically in the world as
far as electric vehicles
and potentially autonomous vehicles well
it's obvious that we're going to have
autonomous
contracts and computational contracts
right
out there engaging in the world like
kind of on these
distributed ledgers or kind of outside
of these distributed ledgers in this
decentralized fashion
so i would say that's kind of the vision
for the future but like anything
who knows when that's going to happen of
course that's a future that we all like
imagine who knows
exactly it's aspirational um
so like the thing that i would kind of
back up and say is that
if we imagine this physical world is
happening
and these changes are happening then
absolutely
software will happen because software is
also going to be participating
in this new these physical changes um
so with that in mind of like where i see
like this future
and where i see like um wolf from
blockchain labs is kind of the
subsidiary of wolfram research and
the the r d that wolfram research is
driving
um we know these things are going to
happen in the future we know that we're
going to participate and we're kind of
grinding away and moving at that
um one in terms of like the blockchain
integration stuff that i mentioned
earlier
so we're going to increase the
performance and the ease of use as far
as those unified functions that work
across
different blockchains uh that uh
wolfram blockchain labs will will create
i think particularly you're going to see
more and higher performance
in this analytics kind of use case
because that's one of the things that i
think we've been able to develop
um over time we've worked
with kind of the the dlt companies
to integrate them with this blockchain
integration
and if there's anyone from like a dlt
company or foundation
this is like your cue to go to the
blockchain
labs website and fill out a form and
contact
contact us um so you have that real
layer
but now that the other really exciting
thing is that
also with developers and users to kind
of make up
you know how things are moving along um
in the space as a whole
you're going to see a lot of stuff i
think in terms of analytics
um it's one of again the strength of
wolfram's in terms of
data science and analysis so it's only
natural that
you know we're going to be really great
and really useful for developers
and users in this area yeah
um cool sorry i just uh it
it is um i think it's to speak to what
you were talking about with the software
versus hardware i think it's
a lot easier for people to picture
themselves using
you know the the smart watch or the
autonomous car
not really thinking about all the stuff
that's going on behind the background
and i think that
you know exactly behind the scenes is is
where uh wolfram
kind of shines in a lot of ways um and i
always think of
uh people you know if if they haven't
heard of wolfram then
they've usually heard of wolf from alpha
and they don't realize that that's
actually powering
you know all kinds of stuff uh you know
answering services like siri and stuff
like that
right there's there's a lot of that so
um yeah and
i mean they say that blockchain is the
future so i i think
i think you're spot on it's it's going
to be pretty much everywhere
yeah absolutely i mean that's a really
good point because
like when you look at that computational
facts area
um in the uh computational
intelligence area we've already made
this tremendous mark at wolford research
we've we've been right there
when um virtual assistants
were kind of conceived right like we
were literally right there
um and so when you see many of the
virtual assistants that are out there
just kind of in the world again like
acting on information in your
environment in in some cases
and giving people responses and
information i think
this kind of the approach that we took
in terms of um making authoritative data
computable is the exact same approach
that's necessary for this computational
facts area
and again i think what people are going
to see in the future in that area
is stuff is going to move from the the
test net versions that we have
out in the wild that people can actually
poke around with now
they're going to be actually out in the
wild and
being used um so that's really exciting
as well
and i think that in general we're
learning
more about how people are planning to
use
things within computational contracts or
smart contracts so we're getting better
and better
um in that particular area as well and
as you said i mean
distributed ledgers are kind of this
backbone in many
in many ways of these computational
contracts or smart contracts
that are that are out there they're able
to run
um on them or better inform them
depending on
the model of the the ledger itself um
but it may be that people they replace
systems and processes that people
um are familiar with now
like maybe the title of your house or
how real estate is kind of changes hands
from from one person to another
and instead you'll have entities because
people will tokenize
buildings or maybe even communities
themselves and people will buy
like small pieces of those things in a
way it's kind of fascinating to think
about
um but for the large part and this would
this would be i think a success is you
know
people won't really see it at all it'll
just be taking place kind of behind the
scenes and they'll be just
they can take it for granted and that
that would be phenomenal
it's great i mean it's good on both
sides because the
you know if you yes well it's simple for
people i guess is the main upshot of
that it's
people don't have to worry about what's
going on behind the scenes so
right exactly and i don't think people
want to like
it's i don't think it's necessary i mean
that's what technology really should do
it should make our lives easier
and not make it difficult to understand
what kind of what's going on
and i think with a lot of the
applications um
that will come out um
you know over time in this decentralized
space
they will give people more options
around
privacy make their lives hopefully more
secure
and make it easier and give them more
options and kind of more freedom
in a way so i think that
that kind of is a good segue as well to
what we're doing in education
and that's to help again like with the
social aspect
technology aspect and legal aspect is
make sure that people kind of have a
good understanding of
um what's going to happen both the
interesting aspects
the aspirational aspects as you
mentioned before
and then also uh like the limitations in
many ways
um so i think with the education
um one it's like we just have
we're right on the cusp of releasing
stuff we just have the
the visualizations and other stuff that
needs to be done there and again like if
anyone is out there watching this and
they wanted to
use materials and look at materials
absolutely
contact us because we can just make
stuff available
but we hope to expand there into like
developer stuff as well so not just like
general education but then also
education for developers so yeah so
we're making trying to make everyone's
lives a little bit simpler
and uh hopefully more secure along the
way yes um and i think that's yes that
seems like a good note to kind of wrap
up on
um so yeah this is uh really impressive
stuff
honestly i i'm really excited about a
lot of the blockchain
stuff that's been going on with wolfram
lately
anyone watching at home you can as john
said uh
several times you can go to
wolframblockchainlabs.com
uh find out more uh watch out for the
course that hopefully should be
up on wolf from you whenever it's
completed uh and if you're working on
any
blockchain cryptography dlt projects
definitely keep the wolfram language in
mind because we got a lot of
new and upcoming features there so
thanks a lot for talking to me john
yep thank you bye-bye
thanks for joining us you can check out
other wolfram tech talks live coding
streams and more on the wolfram research
youtube channel
or see what else is new at wolfram.com
you